we haven't done anything on weed lately
most of our stories have been good about
weed it's slowly getting legalized
especially medicinal people are
understanding that it's not going to
kill you and in many ways can help you
especially if you're sick but now
lip-balm weed is the newest trend in
weed but don't take my word for it let's
look at Fox affiliate on the marijuana
wax
it's a marijuana product that is
catching on with teenagers and Sarah's
got the details I want to look out for
okay I had never heard of this it's done
by I know until very recently it goes by
the name wax butter and honeycomb on the
streets and it can pack a kick equal to
15 to 20 joints of marijuana let me show
you what I'm talking about here this is
a picture of the product from our sister
station W AGA in Atlanta wax looks and
feels like lip balm it's made from the
oils of marijuana plants and has a high
level of THC that's a chemical that
produces a high police say while it is
easy to make the ingredients needed to
make it are flammable which could lead
to burns or even cause a house to
explode like local dudes really like the
way their cadence that which they speak
at all times and it might blow up your
eyes it's just terrible cable news all
right but I do think the weed wax is
kind of an interesting thing so we've
got some more info on it waxed is also
called BH o which stands for butane hash
oil or butane honey oil the weed is
placed into a long tube or pipe which is
then hit with a rush of highly flammable
butane more than 80% pure THC that's the
stuff that gets you high it's gonna get
you higher faster
it's rumored to be the most powerful
form of marijuana on the market and a
wax can be extremely hallucinogenic so
that's good for the mushroom people and
one more video for eeeh this is this is
someone smoking the wax
[Applause]
[Music]
that is uh that is Roscoe rapper Roscoe
Roscoe - that is Roscoe - one of my
favorite rappers why why would you want
to be that high I think is the first
question I - I literally can take one
puff of a joint now and I'm good to go
for three hours and it's obviously for
my severe back pain coma no that's um
but like really I'm good to go like so I
I do think there's something nice about
this wack stuff which we'll get to but
why would anyone want to be am i just
old now is that okay I guess I did that
in college you know it comes down to
efficiency yeah we as a people have less
time we don't have time to roll fifteen
joint right and smoke them all so you're
like getting stoned for a year right
yeah that's like a year's worth of stone
age into one efficiency I don't even
smoke I'm like in the minority
I don't smoke at all but I get the
thinking I honestly get the
understanding that you just want to get
it done as quick as possible so you can
get to the other things you have to do
yeah Lisette you love the way efficiency
the ignition think she gets the
efficiency every eighty percent THC
right this is that did not look fun I
don't know if I mean Roscoe didn't look
like he was enjoying himself he was
coughing he was on the floor I mean if
you smoked a joint all by yourself and
you're not that used to that you know
the THC you end up feeling awful you can
get paranoia you might end up falling
asleep you start hallucinating right
when you have something this powerful
I'm afraid that people might actually
start acting like they do when they're
like on mushrooms or meth or some like
that like what can be the potential
effects but I don't know in mushrooms in
my eyes look let's just keep us pleasure
than that
in terms of the hallucinations they both
start with an but that really they're
nothing alike right but when it's this
powerful you're really looking into
right a substance that's no longer
really an herb like I think the whole
appeal of marijuana is that it's this
natural thing that you find in the earth
that's grain and you smoke it and it's
like happy and no chemicals here you're
using butane and a lot of times this
butane can contaminate the wax and
you're gonna be inhaling that like
it's awful for you like let's keep it
green that's that's what it's all about
let's keep it green Wow she's never
smoked weed you're obviously on the
marijuana Council of America Oh green so
right so I do think that's part of it
that when you smoke weed there is this
sense of like this is something natural
and whatever and the fact that you need
that butane that amount of heat that's I
think that's the appeal no one's sitting
down and saying you know the THC levels
in this are so high and you need the
special tours no hey boy it was like yo
I got the best on earth you're
gonna be high for days like this is
crazy and he's like yo let me get it
yeah like there's no education there's
not like a sit down let's talk about
this let's talk about the effects yeah
he doesn't care so even though you're
even though you personally don't smoke
weed you're for the legalization later
but no no I'm for staying out of
people's business like look if you need
it especially for medicinal issues yeah
then by all means do what you have to do
yeah I don't get in your business don't
get mine you know what I do in my house
maybe I do something else you know I'm
just really for people being able to get
the things that they need to make them
feel better and if that's it then by all
means for me this whole waxing is really
just a dick-measuring contest like oh
yeah you can smoke two joints I'm gonna
smoke all this wax you know oh my gosh
and they're really just trying to prove
that they're like macho and like a
brother like what I can do it's it's
kind of ridiculous to me yeah so do the
pro weed people behind the wax thing
like I get it's like a cool idea or
whatever like I get that part but are
they actually harming the legalization
effort because then people see those
videos
and then yeah then they're gonna say oh
my gosh so you know the you know my
neighbor's house burned down because of
marijuana
marijuana's burn down houses that's the
dialogue that we're going to start
hearing that's going to be the narrative
and that's incredibly harmful I'm I
don't know I think that there are better
ways to smoke weed and get that THC that
this form seems highly dangerous I think
I might go there
I just feel misled like I really thought
it was gonna be a lip balm yeah one song
well I feel like if it's really like a
lip balm like almost like an edible if
you just put it on your like high and
it's not you're not falling over like
Russ Russ that's sort of where I thought
it was going you're marketable
absolutely they're missing the big
picture here they buried the lede yes
why not for someone that doesn't smoke
weed you've got a lot of good ideas on
how people should ingest we
[Music]